Panic had set in researchers were
frantic there was a buzz of activity not
born of excitement but from sheer
widespread Fear The Scarlet King was
coming nobody at the foundation knew
when or even how the Monstrous
multiversal Tyrant would spring free and
bring endless chaos with him but
everyone knew it would be soon they'd
all had the same warning the same
nightmare in fact it wasn't just the
foundation either but the entire world
had shivered in their sleep sharing in
the bad dream of the destruction that
was yet to come the Personnel of the SCP
Foundation were on high alert of course
the organization had been aware of the
impending threat of the Scarlet King for
longer than almost anyone else but that
was part of the problem through some
anomalous dream had by everyone on earth
now everyone else knew the foundation
was less interested in uncovering the
source of the Nightmare and more trying
to counteract its potential side effects
that was what potentially off for the
Scarlet King the power he needed to
enter into reality after all the more
people knew about him tried to
understand or to find the Eldritch
entity the more power he was able to
obtain we have an army one member of
personnel chimed in during a frantic
debate we have an almost unlimited
fighting force that are specially
trained to handle anomalous threats the
MTF are you crazy another argued the
mtfs are certainly not unlimited at any
rate the Scarlet King might be one of
the most powerful beings in the entire
Multiverse how can our troops even our
anomalous units even hope to stand
against that you're proposing sending
our people into a Slaughter they'd all
be wiped out in the moment one of the
other researchers concurred we need to
be focusing our efforts on the amnestic
rollout if we can distribute enough to
the population we can wipe their
Collective memories of the dream from
the other night they'll forget and that
should slow the approach of the Scarlet
King SLO oh him maybe but it won't stop
him the first retorted full-scale
retaliation is still our best option
even now while we try to come up with a
strategy that could be enough to draw
him in we're willing him into existence
as we speak uh what about deploying
another SCP came a voice from the edge
of the group it belonged to Junior
researcher Jake Harrison a relatively
new member of the foundation who had
been reading up on files related to The
Scarlet King he knew that in trying to
understand and come up with a way to
best the murderous multiversal warlord
that he was inadvertently feeding him
power but Jake seemed to have stumbled
on the one solution that everyone else
had overlooked there was already another
anomaly that might have been perfectly
suited for defeating the Scarlet King
what do you suggest Harrison one of the
other researchers that you really think
something like 682 would be willing to
work with us and destroy the Scarlet
king that's absurd I heard 682 is meant
to be one of the Scarlet King's Children
another remark no not 682 Jake argued
turning to the researcher that had just
made a comment about the entity's
supposed children a group of anomalies
that we believe to have been born of the
skull King himself but you're on the
right track we use scp-999 the group of
researchers looked dumbfounded at Jake
he couldn't tell if they were about to
yell at him or they would all burst out
laughing to his surprise they actually
looked to be considering his proposal it
was widely believed that scp-999 the
adorable blob of orange slime known as
the Tickle Monster was actually the
final child of the Scarlet king that's
not entirely implausible one of the
researchers answered scp-999 is believed
to be an Ultimate Force for good that
could in theory defeat his father the
Scarlet King is meant to be unparalleled
chaos the two could cancel each other
out another theorized but the Tickle
Monster sorry
scp-9999 it's an infant a child someone
else pointed out even if it could one
day beat the sky solid King it's nowhere
near strong enough to yet we might have
days minutes even before he arrives and
I don't know if 999 has the power to
stop his father then what if we could
make him stronger Jake replied a risky
idea of brewing in his head surely you
aren't suggesting suddenly a loud
rumbling rang out like an earthquake
only much louder and instead of coming
from the ground below the noise was
coming from the sky the foundation's
researchers raced in the nearest window
or ran out of the buildings they were in
to turn their gazes upward scored across
the sky above was a deep blood red crack
a wound in the fabric of reality itself
it was huge almost covering one horizon
to the next and everyone looking at it
knew what it meant that crack in the sky
heralded the approach of the Scarlet
King Junior researcher Harrison spent
the next hour impatiently trying to get
a hold of someone anyone who could
approve his proposal the o5 council were
already swamped with suggestions for how
to stop the Scarlet King each one
contributing to his rapid approach
eventually Jake made it through and
spoke directly with a representative an
underling for the o5 council listen to
me he urged I know this isn't your
department but I need someone to sign
off on this please the lives of everyone
in this reality could depend on it what
are you proposing the Clockworks scp-914
Jake answer we place scp-999 inside
speed up the process and make him strong
enough to stop the Scarlet King it was
an astronomical gamble using the
anomalous Improvement machine
constructed of a multitude of clockwork
components cogs Gyros gears scp-914 was
a device that could be used to enhance
or refine any object placed inside its
input Booth depending on the setting
items could be transformed destroyed or
vastly improved using the Clockworks
rough setting disintegrated to any test
subject while cores dismantled it to its
base components one-to-one replaced any
item with an almost identical copy then
there were the fine and very fine
settings the former would cause 914 to
improve any item and the later capable
of the same but with one key difference
very fine would refine an object even
more usually by giving it anomalous
properties Jake had read up on scp-914
and knew that the foundation had
permitted researchers to conduct tests
using the machine however following a
catastrophic test nothing organic could
be tested in scp-914 that was a strict
rule no biological organism or living
thing of any description was to be
placed within the Clockworks it was
Jake's hope however that desperate times
called for desperate measures surely
with the Scarlet King almost upon them
the council would waive the restriction
and allow scp-999 to undergo refinement
the o5 council representative zoys cut
out after Jake made his suggestion there
was a long pause even without the
pressure of incoming Calamity the
silence seemed to extend for a painfully
long time suddenly someone else spoke up
in their place a modulated distorted
voice it quickly became clear to Jake
that he was talking directly to a member
of the o5 council under a different set
of circumstances he might have felt
honored but right now it was almost as
scary as the threat of Destruction by
the Scarlet King listen closely Junior
researcher the council member said on
the other end of the Comm line you may
think you understand as cp914 you may
even think that it might Aid Us in
stopping the current crisis but you are
far far mistaken you will cease this
current course of action immediately
your proposal has been denied but wait
Jake protested surely it could work I
know biological material is impermanent
inside the Clockworks but that doesn't
mean it can't affect living matter
scp-999 is a living organism if he
really is everything we think he is and
we just put him through the refining
process he could nove researcher
Harrison the voice part using the
Clockworks would mean we risk losing 9
nine nine what are you talking about you
appear to have a fundamental
misunderstanding of scp-914 Junior
researcher the council member chastised
it doesn't merely improve upon existing
objects but replaces them with a new
version it creates if we were to place
999 inside the creature as we know it
would be gone forever and if it really
is capable of stopping this catastrophe
we will then have lost our Ultimate
Weapon against the Scarlet King but Jake
trying to say enough every second we
wish discussing our options the more
power the Scarlet King is able to amass
so why don't we stop talking and
actually do something the young
researchers shouted giving in to his
frustration and losing his temper the
calm line went dead there was no one on
the other end anymore another rumbling
sound rippled through the building even
louder than the last Tremor Jake ran
towards a nearby window and looked out
in horror it was already too late the
red crack above had split open wider and
like a tidal wave hordes of nightmarish
creatures came spilling out raining down
on the world and commanding them sending
forth his minions in a flood of
Destruction was the Scarlet King himself
Jake was done waiting for permission
from the council he sprinted as fast as
he could through the facility past Panic
researchers fleeing for their lives
while security officers and MTF troops
abandoned their posts in the futile hope
they could survive the end of this
reality and all others Jake forced
himself not to pay attention he needed
to find scp-999 the playful blob was
often free to roam around the facility
improving the days of anyone it
encountered so all Jake needed to do was
find anyone who seemed happy despite the
catastrophe and scp-999 wouldn't be so
far away outside the world began to
resemble the nightmare that everyone had
experienced the night before cities were
burning as monstrous Abominations tore
through innocent civilians and ripped
buildings and cars to Trends reducing
every nearby standing structure to
little more than Rubble with frightening
speed and ease the Scarlet King and his
armies had been waiting for this moment
for centuries Millennia eons even and
now nothing could stop them from
unfueling Pure indulgent Chaos on this
reality they had their work cut out for
them subjugating and destroying the
entire Multiverse but that isn't to say
they weren't enjoying it people across
the Earth were being killed in droves in
the name of the Scarlet King he diverted
a significant portion of his forces to
attacking the SCP Foundation itself
while the boots on the ground MTF troops
the ones that had remained loyal were
usually a formidable fight they were no
match for the Eldritch armies of the
Scarlet King The Horde began to set free
other anomalies kept locked up in
containment either by accident when they
stormed the foundation facilities or
intentionally seeking out their cells to
Spring them some scps tried to stand up
to the scrod King and fight back back
the likes of the plague doctor the
Specter and scp-2800 all tried their
best to ward off the oncoming attacks of
the Scarlet King's foot soldiers they
lasted longer than those who decided
instead to run away turning heel and
trying in vain to escape the destructive
reach of the Scarlet King even anomalies
like scp-106 who could escape to other
planes of existence or pocket Dimensions
weren't safe in hiding they were only
prolonging the inevitable the Scarlet
king would find them all no corner of
the Multiverse was safe and of course
some scps thrived in the catastrophe
creatures like scp-682 the infamous hard
to destroy reptile found themselves free
to exact revenge on the foundation and
Humanity at large of these not all the
anomalies gave away their allegiance 682
in particular was too busy killing
anything and came into contact with
whether they were human or part of the
Scarlet King's Army but other scps
gladly saw more fealty with the Crimson
Cosmic conqueror forming alliances with
the entity responsible for setting them
loose and joining the mass of
monstrosities he had Unleashed and yet
in the midst of all the chaos the
Calamity and the millions upon millions
of deaths one Junior SCP Foundation
researcher was still searching for the
wholesome orange blob Jake Harrison had
put all his chips on scp-999 and
eventually tracked the Tickle Monster
down the building around him was
crumbling attacks from the Scarlet King
and his minions bombarding every second
as Jake ran into the mess hall his eyes
instantly caught sight of the ball of
orange slime cowering under a table hey
hey he whispered hoping to coax it out
it's okay I know there's a lot going on
right now hell it's the end of the world
outside but if you come with me I think
we can fix it together come on little
guy what do you say as if in reply 999
immediately leaped up out of its Hiding
Place Jake caught it in his arms
instantly feeling a wave of bomb wash
over him thanks to the tickle Monster's
calming anomalous effect he tried to
stop himself from fully succumbing to
the Good Vibes that the gelatinous
creature provided after all he still had
a job to do and time was short the
Scarlet King and his invading Army might
have seen for the most part to be
indulging in wonton destruction
decimating cities and Foundation sites
killing humans left right and center but
Jake figured that if there was any
method to their Madness then scp-999
would be at the very center of it not
even the Scarlet King knew for certain
if scp-999 really was his offspring
maybe he had heard the rumors and wanted
to reach the Tickle Monster just before
it had a chance to stop him if it even
could if the Scarlet King believed even
for a second that his supposed son stood
a chance at defeating him and ending his
reign of terror then he'd waste no time
hunting the orange blob down his army of
nightmarish creatures would comb every
corner of the world until they found
scp-9 99 although they might not think
to look inside the Clockworks placing
the smiling slimy SCP on the input Booth
Jake fiddled with the controls for
scp-914 he never performed any
experiments using the machine before but
it was all pretty self-explanatory
throwing the dial to very fine he gave a
moment's pause looking at the adorable
anomaly in the machine the warning from
the council rang in his ears if he
activated the Clockworks he'd in effect
be killing scp-999 either that or the
Scarlet king would do it himself when he
found the Tickle Monster neither
scenario ended well then the Thundering
sounds of the massacre outside got
louder screams coming from innocent
people who were being caught in the
Scarlet King's Carnage there was no
question about it if what Jake was about
to do really could stop all this Mayhem
then it was worth replacing as CP 999 to
do it with a deep breath he flipped the
switch the clicking and clacking of the
Clockworks component's word into life
were drowned out by the approaching
Tremors something was coming no he was
coming Jake thought the very fabric of
the building around him started shaking
brickwork and cement crumbling and
falling apart has a large hand fingers
ending and pointed Crimson claws
wrenched open the roof with ease looking
up in horror Jake saw that the sky was a
dark shade of red towering over it a
colossal crimson-clad Warrior looked in
on the frightened researcher horns
protruding from its head maybe because
scp-999 was still nearby The Blob was
offering him some kind of positive
mental protection otherwise the mere
side of the gigantic monstrous being
above him would have driven Jake and any
other Mortal mad the Scarlet King was
upon Him
came a booming voice that sounded like
hundreds of Screams overlaying each
other the Scarlet King's gaze seemed to
shift slightly turning from Jay because
he lay helplessly on the ground to look
at
ep914 the machine had fully activated
and couldn't be stopped now either
through foreknowledge or some kind of
cosmic sense the Eldritch monstrosity
seemed to know exactly what the device
did
what have you done
the Scarlet King roared he raised a
gargantuan Fist and brought it straight
down through the air towards Jake he
couldn't run the Scarlet King was so
vast in size that there was no way the
researcher would be able to evade the
oncoming strike Jake raised his arms in
a futile attempt to protect himself
despite knowing that the Scarlet King's
fist would likely plunge through the
very surface of the Earth Below but then
again maybe the junior researcher just
didn't want to watch there was a pause
the strike never came it was only when
Jake built up the courage to open his
eyes that he saw what had happened a
long tendril of orange slime had reached
out of scp-914 forming a protective
barrier between Jake and The Scarlet
King suddenly with all the force of a
tidal wave the newly refined scp-999
came pouring out of the Clockworks the
tickle Monster's Mass had increased he
was thousands if not millions of times
bigger swept aside and out of Harm's Way
by the orange slime the junior
researcher looked up in amazement as
scp-999 reached up into the sky able to
look its supposed to face the Scarlet
King recoiled in horror as the Tickle
Monster engulfed him pulling the cosmic
Crimson plunderer into an Embrace as
they hugged there seemed to be a change
in the Scarlet King the Eldritch monster
had spent all his time since the dawn of
creation as a cruel nihilistic conqueror
he had killed and enslaved devoured
ancient gods and slaughtered entire
planes of existence in his quest to
annihilate everything but now held tight
by his gelatinous son his heart shifted
it was as if the Scarlet King's eyes had
been opened and he could see the beauty
of creation the sheer overwhelming
goodness of scp-9999 enhanced by scp-914
undid the evil of the Scarlet King
himself only it didn't stop as the
orange slime engulfed the Scarlet King
in a hug he began to be unmade the
Tickle Monster without even trying to
harm father had been made into such a
beacon of pure positivity by the
Clockworks that the Scarlet King simply
ceased to exist he was unwoven not
killed but rendered without any purpose
he barely even felt any pain but at the
same time was removed from this and
every other universe and still it didn't
stop the newly recreated scp-999 spread
across the world like an orange flood
the Scarlet King's armies the other scps
even the few surviving human beings were
all wiped away
scp-999 spread to every corner of the
Earth turning the Blue Planet Orange as
he coded it purging every single scrap
of negativity all hatred all cruelty all
evil even that of the SCP Foundation
itself the entire world was unmade by
the Tickle Monster not out of malice but
so that nobody anywhere could cause the
Scarlet King to re-emerge at the same
time all that was left was a
planet-sized ball of orange slime lonely
spinning through space now go and check
out scp-999 the Tickle Monster for more
information on everyone's favorite
orange blob of wholesomeness or children
of scp-001 the Scarlet King is scp-999
really his son and explore their bizarre
family tree